is it true that you tricked Sylvester
Stallone who is uh is he a friend and a
rival or just a rival no no in the in
the 80s he was just arriving just
arrived because it was just competition
it was all about who is uh making bigger
movies who has uh what definition and
their muscles who has more box office
success who kills more people
who kills people more creatively
who has bigger knives
but
but the knife but this isn't
it
this is what we use them Predator it's
just a little larger than yours who has
bigger guns at the end I started running
around with machine guns that were only
used for helicopters mounting on
helicopters on tanks it was crazy it was
all out War it was all out War